hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos as they come out
yeah do it welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is
are you garbage the show we sit down
with your favorite comedians we find out
they grow up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host holy coming at you on a beautiful
day
down here aunt toddy's basement she's up
here upstairs she's upset about a lot
that's going on out there
that and the new neighbors not a big fan
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me
he is the ceo of are you garbage he's
the head man in charge
gang he's my best friend in the whole
wide world so the next time you're
reaching for her best pal
do yourself a favor make it a kitty give
it up for kevin james ryan everybody hey
what's up guys as of
i like joe's golf clap as always please
make sure you rate review subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube that's important nowadays i hear
also uh patreon.comgarb but you can sign
up you get bonus episodes over your
garbage every week
you get a you can get a bonus episode of
hard feelings which is me and foley
behind the curtains you know kind of uh
just [ __ ] on each other and yelling
on each other and [ __ ]
and also uh we're good friends well yeah
yeah we get along great off off here
um and then each month with our top tier
patreons we'll play ru garbage with you
guys you ask us questions we ask you
questions it's a live stream it's a good
time
get involved baby good good times thank
you kippy
and how about a nice shout out to our
producer extraordinaire
the pride of the chicago comedy scene
he's the [ __ ] magic man he makes this
all happen
we call him t-bone but his mama calls
him toby
mcmullen everybody what up oh my god
i don't hate myself dude oh man [ __ ]
i've never hated
[Laughter]
the pooch myself there can only be one
t-bone
first foul ball of the show right there
t-bone
and gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest back
with us today
this is a family episode we got a little
bit of company in the house we got a
heavy interior
little star power down here if you
haven't seen his episode go back and
check it out
you know this gentleman very well he has
a special out right now called
i hate myself he has an amazing new
podcast called mindful metal jacket and
of course
he is one half of tuesday's wood stories
ladies and gentlemen
give it up for the one the only mr joe
list
thank you very much unbelievable intro
everything was great
the hot mic was horrendous but
and don't you i i feel like um
trained to clap now when someone does an
intro i'm like oh [ __ ] i don't want to
and it's not because i'm like i want
them to hear it because i don't want to
be the [ __ ] not clapping
yeah yeah yeah i do it when i get caught
on stage sometimes i'm like oh for me
you know what i mean like it's just like
in your head it's a call and response
when i think about this people's snap
when they say i hate the snap it makes
me like wanna
i hate it it makes me wanna kill
somebody i was backstage
with uh a famous comic one time a woman
and i'm not gonna say who but
we were talking and she never heard of
me and she was like how long you been
doing it which i just
made like start to like steam because
i'm like like twice as long as you
and i said like i was like i don't know
like 19 years and her response was
uh and like to this moment as i think
about it i just want i just hate it i
hate her i hate myself i want to do
it you don't deserve a full applause
i'll do this
yeah it's it's just awful and it's very
poetry-ish
or whatever what do you call that um
poetry yeah i went to the store and then
i
um i wanted to say real quick though my
friend dave walsh is a wonderful
comedian
from boston he talked about the clapping
thing and being trained he said one time
he was waiting for the subway
in boston and the train arrived and he
started
clapping for a second and he's like it's
a real he's like i'm not even kidding it
really happened for a second he was like
that was
i'm going to too many comedies
you brought this up what about clapping
when the plane lands is that trashy
i think that's awful also insane i get
if i think maybe
if you had just wild turbulence
it was if it was touch and go you i'll
allow a round of applause and you're
taking enemy fire
and [ __ ] you know i guess maybe
but no that's that's that's garbage for
sure another big one is the movies
clapping at the end of a movie
yeah i also find that gross and
appalling except there's special
occasions on that i mean
yeah i mean if you're like [ __ ]
sundance or something sure but you're
not doing it at the amc on 42nd
i think i did it at the end of the
avengers the first avengers we all did
we all loved it it was great
that's tough yeah that stinks um all
right you know what we're not going to
the movies together i'll tell you that
when i saw uh what was we were just
talking about nick cage movies what was
not no he was in the fire the run up the
building movie what was the 911
united 93 yeah that played in the
theater
and i was living in boston at the time
it was packed and it as soon as it ended
it said like dedicated to the lives and
it
you know the plane is crashing it goes
blank and i turned my friend tom and i
said i smell a sequel
he burst it out laughing so like right
as the movie ends
this guy and no one hears my line they
just hear this guy
howling laughing yeah and uh people were
really upset with him i thought you're
gonna say that everybody clapped at the
end of that i was like that doesn't seem
like a clapper at the end of that one
no i'm trying to think if i've ever been
in a movie where people clapped
that blew you away like that black
panther everybody freaked out everybody
clapped at that one
yeah that movie stinks i haven't seen it
i haven't either yeah
my favorite though is we went all we
went to see ninja turtles one time with
like
there was like 90 of us it was like you
know dante and keith robinson and derek
and monroe and everybody
we went to a midnight showing and the
movie sucked
and like midway through uh keith
it's like the perfect it's the most the
best delivered line ever
it's dead quiet he goes man [ __ ] these
turtles
he walks out dude the pla the whole
place erupted
it was fantastic oh i missed keith buddy
thank you so much for for sitting down
with us
he passed away a couple weeks ago no he
didn't keith robinson is dead
yeah he's in a movie everybody applauded
no kidding everybody snapping at the
funeral
he was a cool jack the shy lights played
it was pretty good um
joe thank you so much for sitting down
with us uh we're gonna ask uh
are we gonna pull up some some questions
from the fans that they wanted to ask
you
ask us uh how have you been everything's
been good i've been pretty everything's
perfect
sometimes you turn into regis
he hits daytime talk show real quick so
i hear you got a new book out
yeah is that true i wrote a new book um
no everything's pretty good uh i'm
nervous with the questions because if
they're asked specifically for me i feel
like they're gonna be hurtful no
no not yeah yeah
why does teeth still look like that he
has money herpes
uh no no no it's not that they were more
general for sure
i'm not going to bring you onto sandbag
i hear your mother's a horn i wanted to
ask you because we were talking about
this before we went on air
uh we had sarah told marchand your wife
yes um
and we were talking about how that was
one of the heart story that she told
about making ricotta cheese out of sour
milk at her house
was one of the best it's insane one of
the best clips that we had
and we were talking to her when she was
on
and she had mentioned when we were
talking about the food that she makes
she said that you don't eat any of her
food
and then you reiterated that on it
before we went on air
yeah that's right how do you wrap my
head around that i don't get it okay
well
a couple things first of all it's not
like i'm like [ __ ] you you douche i'm
not eating your food
um she's a very talented cook and a very
talented person
but i'm i'm garbage so i eat four things
i eat cheeseburgers
hot dogs pizza chicken parm uh
running low i'm running low grilled
cheese uh
cereal chipotle these are honestly this
is what you eat yeah
i just named a hundred percent of the
things i eat yeah wow i'm not that far
off of that to be honest with you maybe
a salad every time
i do the same thing and i'm [ __ ] 400
pounds well i don't eat
a lot of it i have it once a day portion
control big man
yeah i run around i do have a great
metabolism and um
yeah i don't know i'm running around a
lot i guess i work out but mostly it's
the metabolism and i'm pretty doughy
underneath at times
um but so i i just eat the same guy have
you had donnelly on by the way sean
donnelly
was our first episode ever we gotta have
him back okay because he he's the only
guy that has the worst diet than me yeah
he has a very
a very middle-class irish diet yeah
that's what i got like we went to
chipotle
his first chipotle trip was with me and
he ordered chicken and
it was just grilled chicken in a little
[ __ ] potato yeah in the
tin pan and i think that's all he had
but anyways
so normally she's cooking something like
keto
and veggies and the business it's a
bunch of [ __ ] together like good
[ __ ] or whatever but i already ordered a
chicken parm yeah or i'm eating a pizza
what do you guys eat together but
yeah that's some separate meals like
will you sit down with a chicken parm
and she'll sit down with like you know
a quinoa bowl or something occasionally
you'll get away with that that's great i
i do that a lot in my way
yeah yeah well she's on a strict diet so
it's i'm you know
i just eat whatever and you she's got to
wait until the delivery guy gets here
and then you're eating out of a to-go
container
no we don't care we don't have to eat
together well first of all it's pandemic
we're spending every second together
oh yeah that's what's so funny to me
about pandemic is everyone's like the
isolation i'm like i was way more
isolated before
because i was on the road by myself all
the time now i'm with a person
100 of the time um so we'll eat together
sometimes sometimes we'll get take out
together chinese food maybe
but uh oh gee sorry that was me that's
her she's like
um but run in your mouth joey but also
sometimes i'll eat
something that she makes if it's you
know pizza
[Laughter]
where does that come from was that we we
talked about something a little bit on
your episode
it's my family and this is what bothers
me about my family when i was a kid i
have all these memories of them
shaming me because i would only eat hot
dogs with no i was peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches and buttered
are you a plain hot dog guy i eat
ketchup on a hot dog
um so they'd be like you got to eat more
than that he this [ __ ] idiot never
eats anything
and now i'm an adult and i eat fish and
[ __ ] now i'll eat some stuff an
aristocrat
i like the sticks i go back i go back
and they eat nothing like they're like
whoa
you eat crazy now something changed in
you so they're
they they don't eat [ __ ] i don't eat
[ __ ] and they all use this like it's the
best restaurant in the world and i'm
like you've never been outside of 128
in [ __ ] massachusetts everything's
the world
but i'm like you you've been to 30
passports yeah exactly
best indian restaurant in massachusetts
unbelievable my thing is i
i was a super picky eater growing up
like i would like if
i ordered buttered noodles and it came
out with like parsley i would send it
back
no green [ __ ] i don't want you just give
me the regular [ __ ] my mom makes i don't
need anything fancy i'm the same way
and everybody my whole life would break
my balls like ah
who do you got there buttered roll or
like just like [ __ ] on me and then
finally as i get older i expanded
to not get [ __ ] on anymore then i go
home look who's eating steak over here
you know yeah it's like you just want to
break my balls you jerk off
exact exact same story yes same all
right well
that being said i have this is a perfect
lead and this is uh that's trashy guys
as you know when you join the patreon we
will answer
uh your questions on the air uh did we
just get so many submissions that this
is the best way to do it
it's patreon.com are you garbage help us
keep the lights on
um this is from thai tai lin uh have you
ever
made frozen food in the microwave that
the cooking instruction called for an
oven
wait oh oh okay so on the instructions
it says put it put in the oven
microwave it yeah i don't think so i've
i've microwaved things that have
both options yeah which is the trash
that's the trashier option
yeah i've done that for sure but i don't
know that i've straight
microwaved something that you're
supposed to be cooked in the oven have
you ever done that with frozen pizza put
in the microwave
oh yeah all the time yeah uh
i flick water on it before get a little
moisture
that's classy that's what you do
i told you that you run water on your
fingers and then you flick it on there
to get a little moisture that's a hot
tip someone
someone's going to ride in and have my
bag make sure you don't wash your hands
before you want that flavor
on there no you always saw that on
emerald the other night
i do yell bam when i do it you got to
moisten it a little bit
wait i still don't get it you put it on
while it's frozen you flick it and then
put it in or do you open it
after a minute or two and flick well not
frozen in the fridge
like left oh like leftover yes okay i'm
talking leftovers wait we're talking
microwave you microwave leftover pizza
yeah
that's what i thought you were talking
about wait what are we talking about
you take a frozen pizza out of the
freezer that's supposed to go in the
oven like oh
oh yeah like a tombstone or whatever i
see like a tombstone regardless i want
to get back to this flicking yeah
no digiorno tombstone i put in the oven
no
and one of stone is [ __ ] a-okay love
tombstone great film great pizza
but the digiorno you can't cram you'd
have to [ __ ] break it into half of
your knees it's got to be a big
microwave yeah um
this guy's not the executive i thought
you meant out of the fridge like
leftover pizza and you'll microwave that
i microwaved that but first i flicked
the water out because that's important
oh man that's trash google it hold on
who told you that
my mother i think i do it with chicken
farm too you [ __ ]
that's crazy chicken parm yeah i think
it does something
somebody [ __ ] look this up is this
nothing cause something's like that your
mother tells you
i have this with boston a lot where like
patriots day is not a holiday
anywhere else and i didn't know
chinese food on new year's eve that's is
that just a northeast thing
or is that just boston i think it's
mexican philly never i don't know
anybody in philly ever did it
yeah so maybe the flick and water is a
boston thing i don't know
and do you guys let blacks in school
[Laughter]
is that dated down here chinese food on
new year's eve
that was it's i'd literally just two
weeks ago found out that's not a
national thing
but do you think it's just a fat like a
local thing that your family does or do
you think it's
do like you're for all your friends
doing no it's it's a massachusetts
or i guess i think maybe new york a
little bit too it's a tradition up here
i guess because everything was always
closed but i thought in america
everyone's getting chinese food and it
was only because sarah was there who's
from texas
and she was like we never did that and i
was like you [ __ ] kooky british
family
and then we looked it up we did some
research and uh yeah we're we're
[ __ ]
yeah i know i've heard of my jewish
friends growing up
on christmas day they'll go to a movie
and get chinese
right but do they flick water on the
chinese that's the on the
wheat on the waiter on the chinese
people
damn that's flicking water but why do
you
do you prefer the microwave over the
toast or like over the oven or is it a
time thing you're like i just want to i
think it's a time thing
but sometimes again my my mother's
classier than i am so
if we have leftover pizza she'll put it
in the oven she has a stone that's the
best
that's not garbage right it's [ __ ]
it's a slice leftover pizza in the oven
it's [ __ ]
fantastic only if you're flicking water
but if you got a stone especially that
that's something that's pretty good yeah
i don't have a stone i've never even i
don't even think i've ever used one or
seen anybody use one what a cooking
stone
yeah i've seen it quit bragging
we dug it out of the backyard yeah yeah
put some rocks in there
uh all right this is from brian in the
same world do you cut your pasta on the
plate before you eat it
or do you do the standard twirl no i do
it twirl if i'm at a restaurant i use
the spoon like an [ __ ]
like i look i make it look like i'm
saying what you're doing yeah and then
uh no i've never cut pasta in my life
that's a it's funny you mentioned the
spoon i don't know who i was talking to
it was on it was on air or with yeah i
think
was it you saying that using the spoon
is trashy
bone i was always uh brought up to
believe that using the spoon was for
children
and that adults go fork to plate i was
i was always thought that that was the
traditional way to eat pasta that's how
they did it in italy that's what i was
told yeah i've been in italy
they give you a spoon oh they do yeah
all right i've also been to italy no he
hasn't
don't lie to the people joe i went there
i will say this
now you're gonna maybe think this is the
airport i had a layover you're gonna
think this is garbage maybe i don't know
what the water thing in the stone
i'm not sure where this is gonna fall
but
in upstate pennsylvania they would make
my my
aunt would make spaghetti okay and then
she would put it in a skillet
and she would slice it up so it was like
she would make it like little tiny
little pieces
and then you would eat it like that and
it makes it [ __ ] so creamy and so
good
that sounds like rice yeah
oh italian rice i think she made rice
like you're like i wanted spaghetti
she's like it is i cut it up don't worry
this fat little pepper won't know the
difference
let's face it gang i'm fat and he's bald
and making multiple trips to the post
office is not
the way you want to spend your time that
is why we recommend mailing and shipping
online at stamps.com
stamps.com allows you to mail and ship
anytime
anywhere right from your computer you
can send letters ship packages
and you pay a lot less with discount
price
rates from usps and ups and more
yeah uh guys we sams.com has saved small
business thousands of dollars over the
years and
hours and hours of your time it's easy
with stamps.com you get the services of
the post office and ups
all in one place it's easy peasy one
stop shop
plus big discounts on mailing and
shipping rates what's there not to love
stamps they sent us they got us a set up
they got us the scale they got us the
printer and everything we've been
sending stuff out of here merch out of
here it's easy if we can do it you can
do it you can do it
from if you got a warehouse if you're
working out of your apartment your car
wherever you are you can use stamps.com
it's easy you use your computer to print
official u.s postage
24 7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send it it's easy
just do it stamps.com is a no-brainer
saving time
and money it's no wonder why nearly 1
million small businesses
already use stamps.com we have a lot of
small business owners that listen to
this show
check out stamps.com if you haven't
already absolutely and gang do us a
favor
stop wasting time going to the post
office and go to stamps.com instead
use stamps.com there's no risk and with
the promo code garbage
you're going to get a special offer that
includes four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale
no long-term commitments no contracts
none of that stuff
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in garbage.stance.com
promo code garbage stamps.com never go
to the post office
again now back to the show
but no that does sound great that sounds
delicious today so good next time you're
at home
cut up your [ __ ] spaghetti regular
spaghetti i'm not talking linguine or
anything like that just regular i feel
like once you start doing that you can't
come back from that though no that's
like a road you can't go to then you're
eating it just with a spoon at a certain
point that's really where i wanted to go
with it
if you want to be like foley folks start
frying your spaghetti please
we made spaghetti pie that was a big
family recipe wow which is like
i think essentially i don't know
anything about cooking but i feel like
it's essentially lasagna but with
spaghetti but basically it was it was
like it came in a big round thing and it
was
cheese and sauce i got the recipe i just
got it that's pretty good
spaghetti pie i mean it's something and
you eat it like a pie you take a big
triangle slice and just give it away
people were [ __ ] on me
in the facebook group about making
spaghetti sandwiches you ever make a
spaghetti sandwich
um you take like texas toast like garlic
bread and you just put the spaghetti on
it and you can either like
fry it like uh like a grilled cheese or
just eat it regularly that sounds
amazing to me and i don't think that's
garbage yeah i know that's like
innovative i'm like holy [ __ ] man i like
that you're a chicken parm guy
oh huge chicken parm guy i'm like are
you like a sandwich or an entree guy
i like a sandwich but mostly the entree
i mean i'm like
known as chicken parm guy in some
circles
um but yeah huge chicken parm that's my
thing yeah
i love a good cp oh that's good uh all
right this is from chris have you ever
worn a deceased
family member's clothes no definitely
not my family i've been pretty fortunate
in my life like my
92 year old grandfather is the only guy
that both all my grandparents are dead
now
but uh i certainly wasn't wearing their
clothes
nor did i ever no no they didn't
i no i'm trying to think of a joke yeah
[Laughter]
what do you know what do you say yeah no
i don't nobody's
in fact i said i've been lucky no one's
died other than all my grandparents but
even if
anyone in my family died i wouldn't put
their clothes on yeah only because
they're [ __ ] nerds
i wore my uncle i wore one of my uncle's
suits to his funeral
wow yeah my uncle mike i got all of his
clothes when
when he died because they fit me
perfectly or all of his stuff
that's weird i don't know that's weird i
used to like it and when i was a little
kid i would wear my other uncle's stuff
he was still alive at the time
but like the stuff that he didn't want i
would wear his old clothes how old was
he
what do you mean how old was he when i
got his stuff he was probably in his 60s
when he started giving me his
hand-me-downs like the stuff that his
wife didn't want to wear anymore they'd
be like
shirts in like the 70s they're like cool
t-shirts it was the 90s it was the
grunge so we were like
you know we were shopping at uh thrift
stores anyway
yeah that i think if you if you're
getting clothes at a thrift store you
might getting it from your aunt is no
different really
plus it smelled like him which i love
that had like this old like detergent
smell
what i'm weird this guy's [ __ ]
microwaving pizza you're [ __ ] looking
at me
i'm okay with this i'm like that sounds
nice yeah it's i don't know that's just
strange to me what do you i would just
be thinking about my dead relative the
whole day
yeah you think about them you wear it in
their honor
i don't think your uncle needed you to
wear his doobie brother's shirt in his
honor
i just here's what's happening in my
mind it feels like it took a serious
tone and i don't want to make jokes sure
i'm trying to pull the [ __ ] out of here
it feels quite poignant and i'm like all
right
everybody right that's cool you asked
the question
sure um okay have you ever worn a beer
t-shirt when you were a kid
oh when i was a kid i was a big beer
merchandise guy growing up
i don't know about when i was a kid
probably not as an adult all the time
and in fact
i got sober and i continued to have them
because they were just shirts and i've
been at it
this is a different question but i have
been at an aaa meeting
with a guinness shirt and i literally
did
the unzip and like i had to zip it back
up
i just had to sit there hot so i've done
that but
as a kid and then being like i probably
get this out of my rotation but
as a kid i don't think so i don't think
i ever wore i think my like my mother
had
some amount of attempt at class and
would be like i don't think we should
have a bud light
shirt on uh you're at a meeting with a
it's a five o'clock somewhere handle
the beer helmet it's just soda guys come
on
i can still have a little fun huh holy
[ __ ]
uh holy [ __ ] yeah i was i always wanted
[ __ ] beer member beer
as my because my family was all boozers
i'm like i can't wait to start drinking
i want to be like that's what i thought
adulthood was i was like yeah you just
start drinking
yeah same i mean spud mckenzie i was
into but i don't think i had any shirts
i love spud he was huge good surfboard
yeah he was awesome but i didn't have a
um
shirt did you ever hear regan's story on
um he was on ari's show whatever
whatever it was called i can't remember
it this is not happening it's not
happening he tells a great story they
tried to some beer company i forget
which one tried to do
like campaign against spud he was going
to run for president
that was it was a dog that ran for
president and brian regan was the
spokesman
and he had to go out in intermission of
a hockey game and like
talk about the dog and uh the story is
online you should check it out it's
hilarious he's the funniest guy he's
worked out too no
and he tried he really regains it up and
it's [ __ ] it's hysterical it's a
great story
so stop listening to this and go hit
pause
i'm just plugging somebody else's show
on youtube needs the money regan really
needs the keys
he's hurting yeah um all right this is
from bilo what's you
obviously you live in the city now but
like if you were home or when you lived
in the suburbs what's your shopping cart
etiquette do you leave it where it is or
do you return it to the little corral
there
no i'm a big returner i see i feel like
i'm not garbage
i'm a very cons if i'm garbage i'm a
considerate piece of garbage
but well that's just being a dick
there's a difference between you know
flicking water on your microwave pizza
and leaving the card out for someone
else to go get you can't leave it in the
parking lot
no you got to return it what if there's
a couple around
there's a couple if you join it with a
couple maybe if it's like the fourth
i think maybe no yeah well i was a i was
a former cart wrangler
uh shout out to acme in newtown
pennsylvania embarrassing
this was last summer i was in the union
too by the way were you really
yeah you're joking they make you join
the teamsters
oh there's the teamsters [ __ ] are the
court guys
yeah all like like retail workers or
i don't know something i had a jacket
local local 519. i didn't see them in
the irishman
hey we got the cart guys here that's the
lookout it's
it's just a fat man i heard you move
carts
yes sir i do i do move carts
uh yeah you gotta return it it's a
[ __ ] move to not return it
yeah well the good ones by the way have
those things out in the parking lot yeah
they have a little slide spot yeah yeah
yeah i don't like that
in the biz we call them the corrals
really
yeah are you a grocery store guy do you
guys go to the store i go to the grocery
store all the time because i buy
you know soup i gotta
i get my soup i don't i never have food
in the house i go and buy it
and then carry it home and then eat it
and then that's it that's it that's such
a new york thing you don't plan for a
couple days ahead
it's usually that no a little bit maybe
some i'll get a couple frozen dishes but
get a large pizza yeah a couple things
like that but not really
is it all stuff like that is it all
pre-made food or is it do
do you ever cook yourself do you ever
get like some broccoli and some chicken
and some this and some that
and go home and make the meal no never i
make a smoothies i
i get spinach and blueberry and uh you
know i put some oats in there almond
milk but i never really cook
ever no i'm a piece of [ __ ] when it
comes to food what's your soup what's
your brand what do you go through
campbell's chicken noodle [ __ ] right
up the middle
i put it in a bowl and then i microwave
it i flick water
and i'm wait you're buying canned
candles yeah no good
holy [ __ ] that's the [ __ ] since the
20s or something like that
i think it's a nice soup i think it's a
nice soup amy makes a nice soup as well
the [ __ ] up i'll tell you that she's
doing okay yeah amy's does all right she
makes a cream of mushroom soup that's
fantastic
maybe i'll check it out but campbell's
wow yeah it's old school
well i am a camp my mother's a campbell
that's my family is a campbell clan
that's a dirtbag make that connection to
be like well it's my last name
representative yeah but not connected to
the family
no no we have no i don't know i don't
want to make it seem like we're doing
well
if he had chicken noodle money he
wouldn't be doing this show oh i would
love that
noodle um all right another in the since
we're in the world this is from the
other side do you eat in bed
no no no i've never i've never had i
don't have uh i eat
my wife out occasionally birthdays and
easter sunday whatever but
usually in the kitchen though it's
strange yeah no i never i've never had
a tv in my bedroom in my whole life well
no
for for a year i did because i live i
had three roommates so it was like a
little room
yeah but um no i don't we don't have a
tv like
the only way to eat in bed would be if
you're watching tv be psychotic if you
were eating in bed
yeah yeah just like just get the plates
and head into the bedroom yeah
so if i had maybe i would if i had a tv
in the bedroom but no i've never done
that
i think i'm killing it by the way i feel
like you're doing so not yet but you're
doing better than your first
your first episode i mean you're talking
about storm in the field when you were
23. i appreciate that
not having a tv in the bedroom though
what is that for i think that's
garbage they're not everything i don't
know i don't have a tv at all
that's we're tv lists jesus tablets
as the manifesto that's embarrassing so
what do you do when you go to bed you
guys watch
watch something on your phones no i
leave i started recently
i'm trying to be like a superior human
being here i'm trying to really be
something so i'm leaving my phone
in the other room and i'll do a little
light reading
but uh sarah watches tick tock in bed
but i try to have no electronics in the
bedroom
wow other than a vibrator obviously
so you put your phone away so you don't
go walk into the bedroom until you're
tired
yeah i mean i get wiped i wake up real
early i have my anxiety in the morning
so i like wake up to pee or whatever and
i'm just like
[ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ] you're this
is you got to do something so i wake up
at like
8 o'clock 8 30. and then at like
midnight i'm wiped
okay so i get pretty sleepy that's
pretty good because anytime i go into
the bedroom i'm wide awake
even if i'm exhausted and tired on the
couch watching tv if i walk into that
bedroom
i just instantly wake up and have to put
something on to fall asleep yeah see
that's tough i gotta that's why
they say you gotta make the bedroom for
sleeping only only
and [ __ ] or whatever i just did so
first
today was the second day i've read i've
listened to something with [ __ ]
uh something like life coach i think it
was tony robbins or something and he
said
he doesn't uh for like 30 minutes won't
consume any
technology in the morning so i started
doing that just like
yeah because i'm so addicted i'd wake up
and grab my phone especially with the
podcasters like tweets and
twitter right right [ __ ] like that so
i've completely [ __ ] checked out it's
been great are you talking about the
actor
tim robbins no tim robbins is the actor
tony tony
with the [ __ ] teeth if you know him
as tony with the d he's gonna yeah
he's got the tony with the teeth what do
you want from me fat he's got the big
chompers
he also does the thing uh where he jump
he plunges into
like a 50-degree uh pool in the morning
oh okay
i i i was doing that for a while and uh
mike kaplan told me he read something
that we have formative years as
human beings obviously but you also have
formative minutes of the day
and they're like the opening half hour
whatever so you shouldn't look at your
phone
yeah and i was doing that for a while
and i'm still pretty good at it because
my phone is in the other room but i do
wake up and pee and then go look at the
phone yeah yeah
i also find myself like i'm embarrassed
by how much i use it because like my
wife will walk and i'll like
drop it i'm like who am i hiding yeah
like this is crazy well you want to know
who's got the likes or what you got you
got messages or what's going on or
over it yeah i'm over it baby it's hard
social media has really [ __ ]
us up it's the worst i think it's yeah
it's horrible
uh yeah i'm so afraid of it i'm so
afraid i couldn't watch that documentary
whatever it was
social dilemma social dilemma yeah yeah
couldn't bring myself to do it
um on a lighter note from walter growing
up would you regularly pee outside of
your house
um not regularly no no
i mean like you were like boozed up or
something and coming home yeah i guess
so yeah
drunk i do like peeing outside because
it's a moment of like tranquility radars
or whatever
yeah i mean but i hike a lot i camp a
lot but like
not just at home not when i was like
living at home i would never be like i'm
gonna go take a piss outside
but maybe if my sister was taking a long
shower or something occasionally
but definitely not regularly yeah i
would sneak down and pee into the
kitchen sink if somebody was in the bank
ah
come on i did that in my apartment a lot
because i had three roommates
and then some of them would take an
hour's shower so i peed in a lot of
gatorade bottles to sink occasionally
did you ever get caught peeing in the
sink
no no i didn't until right now when i
told my roommate
peed in the sink a lot uh growing up my
buddy pat had a little like ceramic
stone like it was like a little boy
holding a bucket it was like you know
two feet tall
yeah i mean his house is the house we
always partied at and right outside like
we'd be outside smoking and like right
there
we would it was it was in the corner
that you could naturally pee in
yeah so everybody for like years we were
just like it was the funniest joke of
just peeing on this little boy and
you're just always looking up at you
like hey how you doing
that sounds funny it was a great time it
was a hoot yeah piano the boy is a
fantasy of mine
well go over to pat's house you can make
it come true joe maybe i will
um have you ever lit this is from
charles have you ever lived in a home
without air conditioning
without central air conditioning for
sure we had
an air conditioner like this is where
maybe it gets a little more garbage
where we had an air conditioner and then
there was no door between like the
family room living room so you put a
sheet up
oh yeah oh yeah i've had that would you
guys sleep downstairs on really hot
nights all in the living room together
because we used to do that
that was big no we never did that we
just
we're hot yeah yeah it was just hot a
fan i always had a fan like
right next to my bed do you sleep with a
fan next to your bed right now
no i would if it wasn't if sarah weren't
around i was for a while i need to have
a noise because i got
tinnitus or tinnitus if you prefer but i
think it's actually tinnitus but now i
have like a little noise maker
thing like a little white noise yeah
yeah all right that's pretty good
yeah it's pretty classy it's a nice
noise machine yeah
she bought it it's like a nice it was a
christmas present
um all right and this is the one
uh this is the one that everybody you
know a lot of people had commented on
uh this is from charles uh did you have
a go-kart growing up
no boy [ __ ] you charles
so this is a thing this is a funny
interesting story maybe
some people think it's a sad story you
guys are animals so you might think it's
hilarious
i can't wait but so i forgot about this
until literally this year or 2020
february 2020
sarah and i were on the impractical
joker's cruise
and oh i just thought of why we were
going the cruise was going to the
bahamas
and we were talking about the bahamas
and i i remembered and i was just saying
this because i had this memory i was
like oh
my parents went to the bahamas when i
was a kid
they traded i had won a go-kart and then
they traded the go-kart for a trip to
the bahamas
and sarah i looked up and it was like a
movie where you kind of say a thing and
then you look and she's like
she just looked at paul like her mouth
was on the floor and she looked really
sad and she's like
what happened and i was like i won this
go-kart and i'm telling the story like
oh
don't worry about it it's not as sad as
it sounds i won a go-kart it was that
like stone's video it was like a video
store slash liquor store in whitman or
abington massachusetts and they had like
a go-cart and it was like put your name
in the thing
and you could win a go-cart really put
my name in
and you and then we won like they called
us oh dude that's out of a movie i know
i've never won anything my whole life
[ __ ] and i couldn't believe it i was i
think i was like eight
and i was like oh my god we have a
go-cart and we went and got the go-kart
my picture was in the paper they
it was me and my dad that's big news and
having to maybe they took
and i still am hoping somebody can
[ __ ] hack the system somehow and find
this photo because it exists
yeah i'm sure it's on the other hand you
looked some i think a few people look
cuz i told the story on
on my podcast but no one seems to be
able to find it does the newspaper still
exist
yes oh you can definitely have it yeah
so you got your uncle looking in the
library on microfiche trying to find
yeah you have to have that that's what
i'm saying
hey yeah probably do it on that yeah so
it's got to be somewhere it was probably
89 or nine julia roberts movie
i'm trying to think it was probably late
80s early 90s but
so we won the go-kart got our picture in
the paper
and then the memory is like so foggy but
i know this happened
we had it and i was like we were tooling
around on my neighborhood
and all the kids were like [ __ ]
jumping and cheering
it was like rocky one and everyone we
were riding around and i
i was like the go-kart guy we never had
a pool or anything so it was like the
first
moment of like oh my god you were it you
were the center of attention baby
and then my parents were like we can't
keep the go card it's just two i forget
what they said it's too much
and they traded it to my uncle's brother
like my uncle through marriage his
brother
and somehow i don't the details get
foggy because i was a child but
he had a trip to the bahamas he had two
tickets to the bahamas and they traded
it like straight up
like he got the go-kart dude it's like
white trash who wants to make it
did you have to sit in your house and
like see this guy zipping down the
street no he lived in a different town
unfortunately
but like kramer but so hey man that's a
girls go card
yeah whatever
what the [ __ ] so he got the go-kart and
my parents went to bahamas and there was
a moment and this part i might have
added this in my head in the story but i
think it's real
there was a moment where i was like all
right okay bahamas all right we'll go to
the bahamas
were like no no no we're gonna go to the
bahamas
that part i might have added that in
hindsight
but you definitely didn't go to the i
did not go to the bahamas they did
and i can like pick they're gonna think
we're gonna go get weird in the bahamas
for four days yeah so they went to the
bahamas
uh you know bob looney got the uh
go-kart he drops him off at the airport
in the go-kart
i got nothing and sarah was literally
i'm telling the story she's like
literally crying and she was like
this she's like i'm not trying to be
funny she's like this explains
so much of like all of your insecurity
and like this feeling
because i'm always like you know sarah
do you love me do you like me
and she's like this is why like the one
thing you had that you loved was just
take it away
and then i told stories we all went out
to dinner and it was like
it was ron bennington and his wife and
um
like a few other comics keith robinson
was one of them
and i told the story and like ron
bennington and keith are like [ __ ]
like
slapping the table and ron bennington's
wife
has like tears screaming not laughing
she's just like
devastated and like was like do you want
a hug or anything and
i do think it's like quite traumatic and
i never uh
put it together i hadn't even thought
about it in like 15 years until
i was like oh yeah i almost went to the
bahamas or whatever
i mean i didn't get to go to the bahamas
and he didn't get a go-kart that is
insane
how could the value of a go-kart been
been
equal to the value of a trip to the
bahamas in the 90s dude so what kind of
[ __ ] hole were they staying in over
there i doubt
my first question see again i don't have
a lot of the details it might be the
bahamas massachusetts it might have been
like um
it might have been airplane tickets only
and so that was like i don't know what a
go-kart cost maybe a is a couple grand i
have no idea
maybe back then but not now they're
cheaper now but in the 90s they were you
know
i would say a grand or something yeah so
maybe it was just the flights and the
flights were 300 bucks a piece i don't
know
how it worked exactly you don't remember
it it makes sense that the
the the hotel and was covered because
that's like what those packages are you
just have to get yourself there
right you can get like four four days
five nights for you know
500 bucks or something what kind of
piece of [ __ ] is
this guy was he a grown man in the golf
cart if somebody came to me and said hey
listen
all right if you had kids and you said
hey my kid has this go-kart
i'll trade you the go-kart for some
tickets to
the bahamas as a man wouldn't you be
like i'm not taking this kid's goal
that's got blood on it i don't yeah i
don't know
i should go back and talk to them about
it go back and punch that guy in the
face
well looking back he was probably you
know when you're a kid everybody's just
an adult adult is just an age
sure you know what i mean like so he
might have been 22 or something like
that that's still too old for a go-kart
because
i don't yeah i don't know i should go
back and
get some details yeah get some closure
on that i think i'm afraid to bring it
up to them because it'll be like this
fight or they'll be dismissive or i'll
be you'll find out they traded your
baseball cards to cover the room service
yes
it's traumatizing but all i remember
like i think i was
i must have been like seven or eight
years old or something because i also
think i wasn't old enough to drive the
go-kart
myself i think i don't remember actually
driving i think i was it was a
two-seater it was a two-seater yeah holy
[ __ ]
yeah i think it was a car
it was nice no am fm radio but i can
remember my sister
in the back seat and um
[Laughter]
you bit that jesus christ it was a
it was a honda civic go-kart or
something
no i it definitely was two seats it was
black and i do have the memory of
driving up and down my street and like
all the neighborhood kids are taking it
yeah it's as cool as you can get as an
eight-year-old the kids must have been
like
what's going on what happened dude you
can't you can't be the kid
that one day has a go card and then
doesn't you're done
no i was finished and i remember talking
to sarah i think i remember
feeling like when you're a kid or at
least when i was a kid like
i was like well that's what they said so
everything your parents say is just
reality yeah they're like we can't keep
it
and they didn't give an explanation they
said it like it was like a dolphin i
found or something
or i don't know i said dolphin a dog and
um
no joe we can't keep this dolphin i want
a dolphin at the video store
but it's like it's like bringing home a
dog and be like can we keep it and
they're like we can't and you're like
all right [ __ ] but i don't know the
reasoning they gave me
but i just thought like okay but yeah it
makes sense because they didn't go by
it doesn't make any sense listen i'm not
saying it's right
it makes sense it would make sense if
maybe you won it and they were like
listen you're too young for it you can't
have it
but to let you have it for a week or so
and then take it away from you
did you have a garage gang want to take
a quick second and talk to you about
our sponsor here on the show this one's
an easy one
because you know them you love them we
love them
everybody loves them of course what am i
talking about kippy
sheath underwear dot com baby the good
stuff
it's the best i mean sheath underwear is
an awesome company the guy made it
if you haven't heard of it i'm sure
you've been listening to this pod you've
heard of it if you haven't tried it
go try it it's this underwear it's made
of this spandex moda it's a it doesn't
smell you can wear five days in a row
doesn't smell
doesn't smell at all and it's got two
pouches one for your balls
one for your wiener or you can put your
balls in the one your wiener and the
other you can combo you can mix match
whatever you want to do big man it ain't
my call it's funny how like we start you
start out with like the sail switch but
now we wear them
and we love them so much right now that
we're literally just talking about them
yeah if you're not using sheath
underwear you're an idiot all right
they're absolutely fantastic
you got to go to sheathunderweire.com
and get down on this action
and if you use promo code garbage what
are we going to get you get 20
off i ain't talking five five percent
for [ __ ] idiots this guy
something else i ain't talking 10 15 20
for chumps 20 for ru garbage listeners
use promo code garbage
it's the best stuff it makes you feel
sexy and if you got a little package it
adds a little
you know it gives you it gives you a
little oomph when you're looking at it
you know what right
i go to the supermarket i go i go
shopping in these things
the funny thing is is when you start
wearing them you're never going to wear
any underwear i get upset when i run out
of them
when they they send us a bunch but when
i run out of them and i got to go back
to regular underwear i'm like
it ruins my day i would rather freeball
it than wear anything but sheath i'll
tell you that right now that's how we're
doing it right now yeah so go to
sheathunderware.com promo code garbage
now
back to the show we did not
was in the living room no we had when we
bought the house this is like a
garbage story too we bought a house with
a garage but the garage door
hadn't been opened in like 30 years so
for a while it was just like filled with
[ __ ]
and then by the time it took like 14 guy
like men to [ __ ]
finally crank it open and then we
cleared it out and made it into like a
family room or whatever so we never
actually had a
operating garage he's like you have to
ask your mother about this
yeah no i i think it's like today yeah
you got to call hey are you just going
to breeze by the fact he said he didn't
he couldn't open his garage 14 [ __ ]
years that was going
to go back to that and then they turned
it into a living room which i
didn't hear any come on i didn't hear
anything about construction going on in
there
no i think you just put a couch and
called it a living room yeah
no it was we when we bought the house it
the people that had it before hadn't
opened it but so it only opened like six
inches i remember like all the men in my
family being like
[Laughter]
and uh and then yeah they did
reconstructive surgery on it and it's a
nice family room it's a fine living room
now
do you step down into it no no no it's
all
nice yeah they really did it up nice
classy
but um no i don't know my garage door
still there
no no it's a nice window it's beautiful
beautiful day window nice
but uh yeah i should go talk to them
about it but i'm like i'm actually
nervous it's like traumatic i'm afraid
to bring it up
you got to man you got to fix that
that's why i'd be so first of all
there's no [ __ ] way i would have gave
that up i would have ran away with the
go-kart
i think part of me thinks i'm like what
if i went and addressed this we talked
about it we worked it out and then after
that i was just like
cured of everything like oh yeah why not
try depression
herpes like it just all went away oh man
i feel great
that's nuts what the [ __ ] they took your
go-kart yeah
it's [ __ ] up it's really sad and it
wasn't until like i said i started
telling the story that people were like
hey man like big fan of the pod but uh
seriously this is uh
this is really [ __ ] up like i've never
heard we've made like
15 000 jokes about [ __ ] kids and and
aids
and race and no one's ever had any
problem and people were like that's like
seriously like an issue man that's
serious
i i keep thinking did you see this guy
really
no he like maybe occasionally at a party
so like i said he was my uncle's
brother my uncle my marriage brother so
he would occasionally be around here and
there
at the time he was dating my other
my mother's other sister so he was kind
of around but after that they
i no i didn't see him yeah he's got the
go-kart he [ __ ] took off
he left down can have any gal he wants
it
that's yeah that's weight so your
aunt and uncle were dating tech or no no
so
this is getting it's hairy it takes more
explanation that you just blew back
no so my mother's sisters were dating a
pair of brothers
does that make sense yeah yeah trash so
my uncle just makes you go no
one know one sister no that ain't good
there's my mother and then her sister
married a guy
and then her younger sister started
dating his younger brother
yeah let's say garbage yeah if they did
get married
mixed in there too no they'd be in that
like
that's not right yes it ain't right no
you can't do that no it would be like if
i know i know the exact relationship
you're talking about
i guess technically it's that would be
like if your sister got with joe's
brother
joe's brother or sarah's brother sorry
yeah yeah that's crazy
no because you'd be showing up to the
party as two different people no
they'd be like yeah i guess technically
i'd be like a nephew
and a cousin it ain't right but there's
no blood related like
i think that happens a lot is like
you're [ __ ] a girl and then you're
like in the 1800s
maybe it ain't happening she's got a
sister buddy nah it's no good no that's
not oh you guys
now now i understand why this guy took a
little [ __ ] kid's go card
because he's already a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] yeah dating
his brother's wife's little sister that
would be an instant
well she wasn't nine she was like she's
like 28 that's what he got the go-kart
for to show off in front of her i think
this happens a lot
up at school siblings date sibling i
think that happens all the time
i don't think what i think maybe as like
as like teenagers maybe like if you're
in school or something i can maybe
see that but we're going to be
in-laws yeah no yeah that's no good
that's
kooky all right i guess i guess i mean i
don't care about these people i'm just
defending it from a point
but yeah he did take my go-karts come on
joe
incest piece of [ __ ]
damn uh yeah you got to follow up on
that yeah i got to get some details
only for like the fans of uh comedy
podcast so they can know the details
damn man but that's cool you want it
though man that's pretty good you got
that going
it was pretty amazing yeah like it was
cool for 72 hours it was great
whoever wins one of those things the
problem with winning when you're young
is like you're like i'm gonna be a
winner
and then like i haven't won anything
since then i'm like wow
and then it's just been nothing but
losing since
yeah look at me right down the street my
new coconut
everything's coming up joe no
it's all downhill from here hey what's
richie doing here
because i i had i had two friends that
both won on double dare
because i guess doubled double dare was
filmed in philly back in the day oh wow
so they came to our high school and they
scouted out for some talent
i did not get picked you get stuck in
the nose
mark summer's yelling at me that's
hilarious
it's that little [ __ ] there but no my
boy two of my buddies both won
the the race car wow the race car was
the big one and it was like
it was like a little mini formula one
race car
and they never actually got it either
they had to pay taxes on it that was the
thing well yeah they got it but like we
lived in a townhouse community so there
was nowhere to keep this thing
chain it up good run yeah it could
somebody would steal it go park it on
the street
but so they never they never got it
either so i guess go-karts it's you know
we had one growing up but you were
hillbillies you had like
like cars parked in the grass and stuff
like that yeah we were trashy for sure
did you take the governor off your go
card kippy no
there was always like you know there was
always the bad kid in the neighborhood
who was like i could show you how to get
that thing faster or whatever you know
what i mean but now we were we could
never [ __ ] with it joe do you know if
your uncle ended up taking the uh
governor
i don't i don't know he wasn't my uncle
he was my uncle's brother
folks that's your uncle okay that's your
uncle no
i i have that relationship and we call
him uncle like you'd call him uncle
steve well we're not gonna be like hey
bill
we never see him he's not around
he's not because yeah he's not he's
still in your guys lives at all
no no is that cut is that aunt and uncle
still together
yeah the uncle's still my uncle this my
uncle brian is still in my life but his
brother we don't
but you because kids can fend for
themselves
seriously like not this is really
bothering me i gotta i'll start with my
parents i'll get back to you guys all
right i'll find out i would [ __ ] call
the young people like yo
i want so-and-so's number i mean it was
30 years ago he's gonna fight against
fighting
seven years why did you take my [ __ ]
go-kart
i but i don't blame him i i would just
hit for him the trip to the bahamas he
had to get off his hand
he got an offer and was like great i'll
take that that sounds great
i've had one of those before i wanted
like a radio something or something
or somebody gave it to me don't you have
to have the tickets in your name they're
transferable
you just call up and say hey i got
package number 1814b or whatever
this is where i gotta go get the details
because it makes it sound
shady i gotta get the more details i'll
come back this sounds like a mindful
metal jacket
two-parter dude yeah yeah no i could
just run the patreon wall
no i remember calling like being excited
to talk to my therapist being like
we got one today buddy get ready
um you go to i went to i went i've gone
to allen before what the hell did
you discuss this with your therapist
okay um
yeah no we talked about it but by that
point i had already been seeing him for
four years and he was just like of
course this is just another example of
not being seen or whatever and you're
like oh i thought this was gonna be big
but that's the thing with therapy
sometimes not to go off topic i always
think i'm like i got something
big i [ __ ] was on a show and they
edited me off and he's like well this is
like your parents when you were nine
you're like ah [ __ ] i thought
i thought it always boils back to like
three things yeah exactly
man i had he called my dad an [ __ ]
and i was like this is weird
he's like well your dad's an [ __ ] i'm
like what
all right i guess so get up and fight
him yeah yeah that's the end of this
relationship
he's called me a [ __ ] before he's like
you're a [ __ ]
jesus yeah he's tough well he's just a
deal i mean you know he deals with a lot
of comedians who you know
don't really hold punches all the time
you ever hear robert dean's spit
slash story robert dean saw him for like
a year
and he's talking to him and alan who's a
great therapist but you know people make
mistakes but he was like you gotta ask
yourself one question
what's best for richard dean
and he's like my name's robert and he's
like i gotta find a different therapist
but i feel because allen is such a great
guy he just you know he [ __ ]
robert richard it's all he's 75 years
old but this big moment he just says
what what's best for richard dean and
he's like who the [ __ ] is richard dean
anderson
[Music]
great great story great guy
oh that's great um joe
yeah that's a wild one yeah in some
lighter news
uh this is from the facebook group uh
shannon have you ever ridden a
mechanical bull
i think i did in your drinking days i
think when i was hoping to
be in your sober days i feel like i did
but
now i'm not i don't know if i did
i honestly can't remember i remember
being in a place with mechanical bull
but i thought that was more for women i
thought the women it was like the sex
it was like yeah it was like you know
you were gyrating around i don't really
remember do you remember from urban
cowboy with john travolta yes
serious business you're
yeah it's weird there was one at family
fun center i think and we would all go
there
but i can't remember if i don't want to
say for sure that i did or didn't
because i can't remember but i remember
being around a mechanical bull i think i
was afraid of it honestly yeah i am yeah
i'm surprised it was at a family center
it's usually like a
road club like a roadhouse bar right no
no i think somebody's going to talk to
your parents to be honest with you
no it was like an arcade type of place
but they had them that kind of makes
sense yeah
yeah yeah i was just at uh comics mohit
like that comics yeah well it's like in
the bar
in front of it's road that wrote it's
roadhouse right yeah comics roadhouse
and there's a big mechanical bullet it
was during covid
uh so like you know half the stuff shut
down and this guy like came in with he
had like the big like yard of beer and
he was like yeah let's go you know and
they were like
yeah the bulls closed due to kobe's this
is [ __ ]
i'm like the bulls closed come on
get a [ __ ] life will you his wife got
hit that night
that sounds like trash um yeah this is
from gary have you ever
have you and your family have you sorry
start over gary
have you and your family or friends ever
worn matching t-shirts on vacation
oh not on vacation no no but like just
around the house
no definitely not we did like ugly
sweater christmas thing but they weren't
matching
um family reunions you guys do family
reunions
no i always laugh at the idea of family
my family was together every week my
family's always
like 30 people it's like there's no no
one ever left
[ __ ] eastern massachusetts so like
my whole life i'd hear like i have a
family reunion i'm like that's hilarious
to me my family's together every four
days
that's funny yeah new family reunion guy
no right i think we've gone over we did
it once we did it once with my extended
family it was uh it was at like a park
in wilkes-barre
it was under up it was under a pavilion
which is usually
the kiss of death those general use
pavilions are bad news not to mention
those things
those things are lightning magnets dude
don't go under one of those things in a
[ __ ] thunderstorm
i'll tell you that right now you'll lose
half the family
but i remember they had uh they had the
grills that were in the ground and
that's what i was like even as a little
kid i was like this [ __ ] stinks
i always like the bar the the yeah
charcoal bar using those things that's
that you gotta get there early and like
hope you get it yeah
you gotta send someone there at like 6
a.m yeah there's leftover chicken in it
from whatever the [ __ ] was the last
weekend
real trashy but that was the first time
that i ever ate dirt
not dirt oh yeah yeah
you got to clarify with you sometimes
joe are you familiar are you familiar
with the dessert known as dirt
oh no no it's an actual dessert oh i
thought you meant like there was dirt in
your chick i didn't think you were
eating dirt but i thought like there was
dirt on your
meal and then you're like oh i just ate
dirt no i don't take a bunch of crushed
up oreos and a bunch of cool whip or
something like it's like cool whip
whipped cream maybe some ice cream
crushed up or and you make it look like
dirt like
earth and soil and then people put it
like gummy bears in it
and a lot of times at like trashy or
fancy places
they'll put it in an actual like ceramic
pot
yeah and you eat out of there without a
shovel that's what it was in
no no i never did that it's super
[ __ ] trashy
yeah that's gross
uh excuse me
uh that and what's what's the oh
ambrosia forget the
[ __ ] with ambrosia joe list no i don't
know much about that i've heard that
word i don't know what that is
it's like he's had a [ __ ] congress
hearing yeah i don't know much about
that
no i don't know anything about that is
there a trashy michael collie only did
this
it was all eyes
no i don't know it's like it's just like
cool whipping marshmallows marshmallows
a little bit of orange juice some
coconut some maraschino cherries
some orange orange wedges but they got
to be the ones from the can
and you mix it all up no that's yeah no
[ __ ]
is there a trashy massachusetts dessert
i don't know i'm not a dessert guy we
had whoopie pies is that something
is that something this [ __ ] guy comes
in here [ __ ] on ambrosia
and then starts talking about whoopie
pies what the [ __ ]
there's so many things that i don't know
what is if it's
national enough i don't even know i
never had it i was always a chocolate
chip ice cream guy
but it looked like a black and white
cookie i think or something like that
it was whoopie pie i give it chocolate
chip ice cream mint chocolate chip
no chocolate chips i think little debit
yeah these little debbie just sells them
whoopie pies
exactly yes those ain't bad yeah all
right then what the [ __ ]
i was ready to kill myself over here
yeah whoopi pie exactly they look like
oreos but it's more like a cakey thing
with some white shirts
but i never ate a whoopie pie um
i was like i like chocolate chip ice
cream and mint chocolate chip ice cream
is
is gay that's like next generation i've
never heard of a family that kept
chocolate chip ice cream in stock well
you go buy it
i would say someone would go get it and
i'd say hey do we have any chocolate
chip ice cream
no joe doesn't like his whoopie pies he
needs his ice cream i don't know if i've
ever seen it
it's vanilla ice cream with chocolate
chips was it are you kidding i'm not
chocolate chip ice cream nah i've never
had it
i feel like you're [ __ ] with me
that's like one of those things
what are you talking about it's one of
the most standard ice creams chocolate
chips wait chocolate or chocolate chip
chocolate chip like what i'm saying i've
never seen that [ __ ]
do you do you know what he's talking
about i mean in theory yeah i know it i
don't i feel like it now you guys are
[ __ ] with me now
i know mint chocolate chip it's green
ice cream or white ice cream
with little chocolate chips in it no the
white ice cream said was for
chocolate chip ice cream vanilla yes
vanilla chocolate chip
if you type in chocolate chip that's
like that's on every ice cream menu
that's right i mean let's say chocolate
i've been most popular like this
chocolate chip ice cream chocolate chip
cookie dough cookies
no no chocolate chip ice cream right
here it's mint chocolate chip but just
vanilla and chocolate chip yes there was
chocolate chip ice cream
before mint chocolate chip that's why
they call it mint chocolate chip
this guy's making some good [ __ ]
points it's like um you know
cinnamon whatever the [ __ ] i don't know
i i cannot believe that i have my
financial life is tied to youtube
so terrible you know chocolate chip ice
cream right
it's vanilla and chocolate yes i don't
think i've ever patreon.com folks
are you garbage what was your brand what
was your what was your brand
briars are you guys a briarfan well
massachusetts of friendlies was like the
big ice cream you go to friendlies
and uh and brigham's is like a big ice
cream
okay you know i know it i've heard of it
okay yeah brigham's is great would you
guys go to friendlies to eat dinner
occasionally if we were lucky um but
yeah they did go over to ice cream and
they'd have the big metal tin and ice
cream get the long ass spoon
and it was tremendous that was something
else and they had good cheeseburger they
still do
yeah good chicken fingers too they've
they've moved into
they've kind of stayed away from the
brick and mortar around our area
but in the grocery stores a friendly's
ice cream is still top shelf did you
have you ever got
have you guys ever gotten the watermelon
roll that they have
it's supposed to look like a watermelon
you cut open it's so good
i love doing that if you go to any ice
cream shop in america
they have chocolate chip they don't have
watermelon rolls or whatever the [ __ ]
you're talking about
it's in the grocery store yeah no
chocolate chip standard you go to any
ice cream shop it's vanilla
chocolate strawberry chocolate chip it's
in there
bang all right what about a milkshake
what are you going for milkshake i like
a vanilla milkshake chocolate's just too
much
vanilla milkshake is uh i like that now
what's a milkshake
exactly you ever get a fribble with
friendlies i love a fribble which is a
milkshake
it is a milkshake yeah i think so but i
love a fribble and that's another thing
i thought
was a standard thing and i went to like
texas and i was like i'm gonna get a
fribble and like
sarah's parents [ __ ] chop me in the
face
we're not with this guy the first time
the first meal i ever had
with sarah's family i'm like meeting the
in-laws the whole thing
and i we went to breakfast and i ordered
chocolate milk and her dad was a big guy
from south africa and he went
chocolate milk is for kitties and he
basically just called me a [ __ ]
like he was just like i was like i like
it and he's like
and basically he called me a [ __ ] right
to my face
elaine's dad for some reason yeah that's
right that's exactly what it felt like
we'll tell him we're frightened
we have to leave that's my all-time
favorite song you know walking down the
street with me and my daughter drinking
a fribble
that is the [ __ ] the all-time line
that's one of the that's one of those
episodes that like i didn't see for like
three or
for like years you know i just never
made it through my cycle and then i just
saw not too long it's such a good
episode oh when jerry's like
i can't go back out there i can't come
back that's why he's supposed to be the
funny guy
amazing amazing brains out all over the
pacific the two of them reaching for
their drinks at the same
beautiful cranberry juice with two limes
another scotch with plenty of ice
shout out to seinfeld huh it's a
wonderful show
pretty good good stuff um this is from
dom uh on the facebook group has anyone
you know been on a game show
or attempted to be one on one my friend
derek is a merchant marine and he was in
he lived in long beach and they got into
their uniforms and went to prices right
they didn't get on nice
but they had the uniforms and so they
went down there uh i don't think they
got on they did not get on
i'm trying to think of other i remember
my friend
submitting for family feud and he was on
like a waiting list but he didn't get on
either
and then there's a comic that got on
jeopardy who
uh raj raj sivarahman i don't know how
to say his name exactly i don't know
really yeah did he do well i think he
did really well i think he was winning
and he lost
in the last in final jeopardy i believe
i always root for
people in uniform on prices right yeah
that's that's a good way to get on and
he had
like gained quite a few pounds so he had
like it was like a skin tight
bursting at the same time which is
always fun raj sivaraman i think is how
you
say his name i feel bad sorry raj if
you're definitely not watching this
people that have been on jeopardy and
done well don't probably watch this show
[Laughter]
ken jennings hit the subject i love the
show that blind guy too
yeah i don't know his name um all right
this is from tim
uh actually no yeah i guess we'll do it
uh have you ever carried a flask back in
your drinking days
oh yes
that's all i got for gifts was flasks
every year i was like oh you got your
new flat i had like a pile of flasks
yeah i was all about the flask
every wedding i've ever been to i had a
flask ah that's a big groomsman gift
yeah
yes exactly love it flash love getting i
mean
getting drunk at a wedding is a good
time yes um sorry i know you're sober
that's all right no i'm thinking i'm
like yeah it's good fun you should bring
up the go-kart again
later you're getting [ __ ] up right oh
sorry dude
um all right this is from carly do you
have a go-to game at a carnival fair or
boardwalk
is there something you re you kind of
you kind of you kind of claim that
you're good at or you have a go to
no i mean basketball the basketball
thing i like i can do that
pretty well and um i like skee-ball but
definitely not like
i'm gonna go there and [ __ ] show you
guys i'm gonna [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
but i think basketball i'm pretty good
but those things are funky i think the
rims are all right they're like cameras
yeah yeah that's also a real trash thing
to make standing there like they dent
the rim see the ball don't
fan i hate when they yell at you when
you walk by especially if you're with
like your girlfriend any prize any size
yeah come on what about you big guy you
want to come up and take a shot
yeah but no definitely not a go-to i
like a dunk tank those are fun
i've told the story on here before but
wildwood's boardwalk the
dunk tank guy down there he was like
five five smoke cigs
painted face as a clown would just get
wasted and he'd sit there and it was the
90s
in wildwood so it's rough right and this
guy
i mean pc was out the [ __ ] window
with this guy
dude any whatever your ethnicity
whatever deformity you had he's calling
you out right wow
to the point where like there would be
like groups of like because he did he
worked until like 2 a.m or whatever and
there would be groups of [ __ ] like 15
people just waiting to kick his ass that
he had like a secret trap door
he had like a police escort to get home
that should be a show or a movie or a
documentary or web series
people would throw stuff they would grab
pool cues and like stat try to stab at
them
it was [ __ ] nuts wow he called me a
fat piece of [ __ ]
at least 15 times yeah that should be a
show yeah somebody should write that
i'm too lazy um
this is from david have you ever
collected coupons from pizza boxes for a
free pizza
no no never did that my mother was a big
coupon collector
but not from pizza boxes she had a whole
she's like a little
red satchel full of things but you know
we were poor we had magnets they give
you a little
like a pizza slice shout out to palermos
they give you a little pizza slice and
once you made a complete pie that's
pretty
good it's like trivial pursuit yeah we
got to give the magnets back we always
wanted to keep the magnets yeah weird
right
that is kind of strange it's like a
pizza casino
um we do we'll cut my mom cuts them out
but we never use them
so we have like 20 free pizzas where is
it on the box
a lot of times it's on the box you like
cut it's like you know redeemed for you
know save 10 for a free pizza or
something
no we never had that yeah you know what
else was a good time as a kid saving
that little white table playing with
that
yeah yeah yeah that was fun around yeah
yeah yeah that thing was great it was
like an ottoman yeah it's ottoman for
the gi joes
oh yeah they got involved for sure
they're pizza i'd put it right in my ass
let me keep the cheese right um all
right this
is we'll do one or two more i've lost
the name here but
is your hometown known for anything oh
yeah chocolate chip cookie we invented
the chocolate chip cookie have you heard
of those
it's always cookies with this [ __ ]
guy whitman massachusetts you can look
it up no one ever believes me
it [ __ ] makes me mad people are like
i looked it up i'm like what do you
think about what i'm an [ __ ]
chocolate chip cookie he's looking it up
chocolate chip cookie was invented in
whitman massachusetts my hometown
it says joe list is lying the original
recipe was created
in the late it says massachusetts yeah
i'll give you that
ruth wakefield whitman mass
oh the toll house restaurant yep
yes burned down right that's where i
grew up like
a couple hundred yards from the toll
house cookie place whatever
did it smell like cookies well it burned
down before
it burned the cookie factory burned
but the sign was what you want to do
um but anyways um great show
yeah um but yeah no so that's that's
what my town is
known for you have anything no but i did
i did the burn thing once and uh
you were doing i was doing a children's
play that's a
home run line i was we were doing a
children's play
are we doing winnie the pooh in front of
like a packed little theater of like 140
little kids
and uh my buddy my roommate who was
playing rabbit and i was
involved if there was ever a perfect
cast and we were out the night before
getting all [ __ ] up
and we were [ __ ] in there doing the
play and he's supposed to come out and
deliver a line saying
uh piglet's house blew away that was the
line
but he came out and he was like piglet's
house burned down
[ __ ] dude 140 kids
i mean i mean he's okay dude tried to
[ __ ] make up for it
that's hilarious cancelled yeah that's
it buddy let's wrap this up this has
been a great time joe thank you so much
for sitting down with us and answering
the patreon questions we appreciate
everybody's questions we love you guys
we thank you guys
anything else you want the folks out
there to know that you got coming up
yeah sure i also started uh
all i do is podcast now i started a
third show it's uh with ron on hershberg
i don't know if you guys know ron yeah
it's great wonderful
and it's called joe and rana on talk
movies it's on my youtube
and we're just we're kind of going
through movies reviewing movies whatever
it is
and uh it's a good time he's got some
real [ __ ] horrible takes
and uh so i trash him it's on my youtube
subscribe to my youtube joe and ron on
talk movies
very nice buddy thank you so much kippy
what do you got for the gang out there
uh
as always please make sure you rate if
you subscribe on itunes number 88 as of
today
comedy we appreciate it uh you can leave
a review that really helps
uh also full video full hd video
available on youtube you can subscribe
there those numbers are through the roof
we appreciate that
and patreon.com you know you can help us
uh keep plugging along here we
appreciate all the support
yes we appreciate you guys we love you
guys and we'll see you next week